I've been saving this date for you
Becca will you marry what abz is so
sneaky when they gave us this exclusive
scene from tonight's show they left it
as a cliffhanger it looks like Ben and
Becca are getting married
or are they here's the deal our et
cameras were there when they shot that
scene and we saw it all you did great
thanks for saying that you don't I mean
it mmm I'm actually ordained and I'm
well I have the ability to marry some
people so today I've invited Becca to
join me at the little white wedding
chapel let's just take this as a little
lesson in how to sexy app what would
otherwise be called and I'm not even
gonna get to first base kind of date
yeah as these to officiate some I Do's
Becca is smart and gets in as much
contact as possible if you're hot
that's that I'm to catch that Becca's
fingers gently run down Ben's arm and
then they hold hands this is what we're
calling the sneaky love touch and notice
the grab this is real
I mean I've you seem like a little bit
like him right Oh reassuring tap on the
shoulder fix the shirt this one ended in
a hug score and we haven't even gotten
to the kisses good look yeah you know I
think love is in the air
I love is in the air at all times during
this experience I think Ben could be the
right guy for me
we give Becca props for her moves
especially when she's up against this
fellow contestant Jojo gets a windblown
chopper ride and some action with both
feet on the ground the other girls
watching of course get catty Ben is
totally unaware
these women are incredibly kind for each
other um their understanding they
communicate well are we watching them
kiss yeah yeah hi all right Ben's the
type of guy girls fight for
I'm so jealous I would not be surprised
if i found my future wife in this group
so far everything is going very well I
hope so but it might not go so well for
you if you get married at the little
white wedding chapel it's kind of the
kiss of death for any Spears and Jason
Alexander tied the knot there so did
Frank Sinatra and Mia Farrow and we all
know how those marriages ended up